yeah welcome to a new video I'm
transporting into the Sicilian here
against than I am maybe from from
Germany even it's got the German flag
not it's no name in there Quincy's have
novelty maybe Queen c7 this is early
yeah well maybe I can can try to
transpose to ac3 Sicilian and the queen
is not in in such a bright spot down
maybe
hmm
yeah I'm thinking takes might be five I
might be five it's not it's not a big
deal really and maybe not be five queen
bee six Bishop g5 something like that no
it's not even in sir hmm
is it taking you five but I mean he's
very very much behind the development
yeah I simply ignore the material for
now just developing quickly 95 a castle
or maybe we should therefore I don't
know you should therefore is probably
even stronger if he takes on c3 our
castle or Bishop f4 intending to dig so
yeah come on let's let's castle first
maybe he can can take on c3
hmm ok I don't have much choice I need
to take you for now Wow and maybe he
needs to maybe he needs to it sir
possible
it looks very very dangerous maybe
rookie one I don't know itself
everything is everything is dangerous
but it's hard to tell and blitz what's
the what's the best way to to go
yeah I was saying I thought night at
five would be strong now actually not if
I've come on that let's go with the
first instinct not think too much
instantly taking it i'm always amazed
just take it why not at least think for
a second like this is so ridiculous crap
that you can take it immediately it's
just I can
we should for everything is very very
tricky now okay check here yeah well
this is not working i mean at least i
hope for some kind of for some kind of
um justice here
check
ok ruki eight
yeah maybe I should have taken before
witnesses would have been at least
easier yeah
so
Jen
so I take now on age 70 should be three
years is also not bad bishop ter taking
on b6 and Bishop c5
yeah it's very difficult to defend yeah
he's returning let's let's take this
it's equal equal material now and he
still got age seven hanging and aged way
I probably played this very badly
because he well he's still on the board
I mean and it really shouldn't be the
case I am I had better ways to to play
this
hmm cannot take okay but I can go here
intending Queen g6 I which would have
been strong anyway from him so Queen g6
is got Bishop f7 or just here
threatening rook e6 and Bishop g5 should
win at least i'm at least the porn yeah
I'm quite lucky in this game because I
mean he played this really
extraordinarily bad and I I simply
didn't refute it I sloppy play and I
still managed to get a winning position
so just hear you Andrew cage three
check
check
check
check
time morning
check
check
yeah it was it was a bit lucky because I
was I guess I simply was so stunned that
he took it immediately I mean why why
exactly you can take on f3 and Bishop
age two and castles for example it's
probably much better yeah it is much
better still good for white but it's
better he just took it immediately
became and then hmm i have a ton of
interesting moves and this this loses
young and Bishop f7 is much stronger
even okay but this this is also winning
and here here exactly okay the strongest
move far this is really strong was
Bishop f4 ok this is really murder it's
a great web move this pin he has no way
if he goes him it's made and ases no
move simply he retreats here then that's
the Queen and this this lets him back in
the game even this is much stronger here
yeah yeah it's just i forgot i simply
forgot that that he's got d5 and this is
this is not clear at all I mean it's
still according to computer a big
advantage for white but it's just like
that that it is this way he cannot
defend on all stuff needs to return
something and this is again I'm very
very much better for me
yeah but it shouldn't even have gotten
to this point but I don't really
understand sometimes that people play
super committing moves committal moves
instantly either I mean really this kind
of nowhere back moves you really should
invest a couple of seconds at least I
mean it's clear that this is super
dangerous to take it and I'm not playing
this move because I didn't see this it
takes in five I mean and you can try
this at least think about it at least a
bit maybe this is better or what I mean
I didn't quite I didn't calculate this I
just thought okay this must be good and
it seems that Queen III is a good move
here but yeah well he never calculated
all of this just took it and this rather
rather clear that it takes a five as
super dangerous yeah okay thanks for
watching